UNDERMINE HIM.
>> Sean: THANKS WITH THAT
REPORT, TOM.
GETTING VERY INTERESTING WITHOUT
A DOUBT A DEEP STATE RECKONING.
IT'S HAPPENING BEFORE OUR EYES.
THE SINGLE BIGGEST ABUSE SCANDAL
IS ABOUT TO COME TO LIGHT.
SOURCES ARE CONFIRMING TO ME
THAT THINGS ARE MOST LIKELY
WORSE THAN WE THOUGHT.
WE HAVE THE NEW LETTER FROM THE
ASSISTANT ATTORNEY GENERAL,
STEPHEN BOYD REVEALING THE DOJ'S
SCOPE IS MULTIFACETED AND BROAD.
THE INVESTIGATION WILL COVER
ACTIVITIES OF U.S. AND FOREIGN
INTELLIGENCE SERVICES AS WELL AS
NONGOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS
AND INDIVIDUALS.
NOW, HERE'S WHAT LIKELY THIS ALL
MEANS.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL WITH JOHN
DURHAM, THEY'RE NOW
INVESTIGATING HOW FOREIGN SPY
AGENCIES, ALLIES OF THE UNITED
STATES, WERE USED LIKELY BY
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION'S TOP
OFFICIALS IN THE INTEL COMMUNITY
TO SPY ON TRUMP AND THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
THE TRUMP TRANSITION TEAM AND
THE TRUMP PRESIDENCY.
TO EXPLAIN THIS, THIS
INVESTIGATION IS EXAMINING HOW
HIGH-RANKING INTEL OFFICIALS
WERE OUTSOURCING WHAT IS
POLITICALLY MOTIVATED DIRTY WORK
TO SPY AGENCIES AND FRIENDLY
COUNTRIES CLEARLY TO CIRCUMVENT
AMERICAN LAWS AND THE CIVIL
LIBERTIES OF THE AMERICAN
CITIZENS AND USED IN AN EFFORT
TO RIG A PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
THAT IS NOW HOW DEEP THIS
POSSIBLY GOES.
THAT WOULD MEAN PEOPLE LIKE
COMEY, BRENNAN, CLAPPER MAY WANT
TO PAY CLOSE ATTENTION BECAUSE
THIS IS NOT LOOKING GOOD FOR ANY
OF THEM AT THIS HOUR.
WE KNOW THE ATTORNEY GENERAL HAS
REQUESTED THAT AMERICAN'S
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES DO THESE
THREE SPECIFIC THINGS.
PRESERVE ALL RELEVANT RECORD.
TWO, ENSURE THE AVAILABILITY OF
WITNESSES THAT MAY BE PERTINENT
TO THE REVIEW.
THREE, BEGIN IDENTIFYING AND
ASSEMBLING TELLS THAT MAY BE
RELEVANT TO THIS REVIEW.
THERE'S MORE.
IN THIS SAME LETTER, THE
ASSISTANT A.G., STEPHEN BOYD, IS
OUTLINING THE INVESTIGATION IS A
COLLABORATIVE ONGOING EFFORT
BETWEEN THE DEPARTMENT'S REVIEW
TEAM AND THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY AS WELL AS FOREIGN
ACTORS LIKE WE WERE JUST TALK
ABOUT.
ONE SUCH FOREIGN ACTOR IS
CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
HE'S SET TO BE INTERVIEWED BY
AMERICAN INVESTIGATORS IN COMING
DAYS.
AS YOU KNOW BY NOW, HE WAS THE
FORMER FOREIGN SPY PAID BY
HILLARY CLINTON, PAID BY THE
DNC, EVEN PAID BY THE FBI AT ONE
POINT TO CREATE THAT DIRTY
RUSSIAN DOSSIER.
THE ONE THAT "THE NEW YORK
TIMES" IS LIKELY RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION FROM THE
BEGINNING.
WE KNOW IT WAS FULL OF LIES AND
PROPAGANDA.
BY THE WAY, HE SAYS HIMSELF,
CHRISTOPHER STEELE, HE HAS NO
IDEA IF ANY OF THIS IS TRUE,
NONE WHATSOEVER.
THIS IS THE SAME UNVERIFIABLE
INFORMATION THAT EVEN ITS OWN
AUTHOR WON'T CONFIRM THAT THAT
WAS USED BY JAMES COMEY, THE FBI
DIRECTOR AT THE TIME, TO SECURE
THE FIRST FISA WARRANT IN
OCTOBER 2016 AGAINST TRUMP
CAMPAIGN ASSOCIATE CARTER PAGE
BUT OPENED A BACK DOOR TO SPY ON
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND THE
ENTIRE TRUMP TRANSITION TEAM AND
THE ENTIRE TRUMP WHITE HOUSE
WHEN HE BECAME PRESIDENT.
LET'S BE CLEAR.
99.9% OF AMERICAN INTELLIGENCE
OFFICERS, WORKERS IN THIS
COUNTRY PERFORMED DANGEROUS AND
COURAGEOUS WORK.
THEY USE THE BEST SKILLS IN THE
INDUSTRY, THE SURVEILLANCE TOOLS
TO KEEP AMERICANS SAFE FROM
TERRORISM, HOSTILE ACTORS AT
HOME AND ABROAD.
IN THE HEIGHT OF THE 2016
ELECTION, JUST A FEW SELECT
HIGH-RANKING BAD ACTORS ABUSE
ALL OF THESE POWERFUL TOOLS OF
INTELLIGENCE THAT WE ENTRUST TO
THEM AND IT'S CLEAR TONIGHT THEY
TRAMPLED ON THE RIGHTS OF MANY
AMERICANS, COMMITTED WHAT IS
CLEARLY A PREMEDITATED FRAUD ON
FISA COURT JUDGES TO ILLEGALLY
OBTAIN WARRANTS WITH INFORMATION
THAT THEY KNEW WAS FALSE.
BY THE WAY, THEY WITHHELD THAT
FROM THE JUDGES.
THEY USED THEIR TOP SECRET
ACCESS AS A BACK DOOR TO THE
COMMUNICATIONS AND THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN, TRUMP TRANSITION AND
EVEN THE TRUMP PRESIDENCY.
WATERGATE WAS NOTHING BUT A
BUNGLED BURGLARY.
THESE ACTIONS REPRESENT WHAT
WOULD BE A CLEAR PRESENT DANGER
TO OUR CONSTITUTIONAL REPUBLIC.
THESE TOOLS OF INTELLIGENCE ARE
SO POWERFUL, IT'S THAT SERIOUS.
THAT'S NOT ALL.
THEY USED UNDERCOVER INFORMANTS
TO SPY ON TRUMP CAMPAIGN
OFFICIALS AND ANOTHER ATTEMPT TO
SPY ON TEAM TRUMP.
THEY SPREAD CHRISTOPHER STEELE'S
RUSSIAN LIES THROUGHOUT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, THEY EVEN
LEAKED TO IT THE PRESS TO
INFLUENCE THE 2016 ELECTION.
YES, IT LOOKS LIKE THEY USED
FOREIGN INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES TO
SPY ON AMERICAN CITIZENS SO THEY
CAN CIRCUMVENT THE AMERICAN
CONSTITUTION AND AMERICAN LAWS.
SADLY WHAT I JUST OUTLINED IS
THE TIP OF THE ICEBERG.
THIS IS DANGEROUS, THIS IS
CRIMINAL CONDUCT FROM TOP
OFFICIALS IN THE U.S. GOVERNMENT
AND THE BIDEN-OBAMA GOVERNMENT.
IN COMING WEEKS, MONTHS, BARR,
DURHAM WILL CONDUCT AS THEY SAY
A BROAD INVESTIGATION.
WE WILL GET THE ANSWERS.
MAKE NO MISTAKE.
WE'LL GET JUSTICE.
ON THIS PROGRAM, WE TAKE
GOVERNMENT ACCOUNTABILITY AND
THE POWERFUL TOOLS OF
INTELLIGENCE THAT ARE DESIGNED
TO PROTECT US, NOT BE ABUSED.
WE TAKE IT ALL SERIOUSLY.
THAT'S NOT THE CASE AMONG
DEMOCRATS ON THE HILL.
WE SAW THIS ON DISPLAY
YESTERDAY.
JERRY NADLER DUSTING OFF THE
COBWEBS AND THE MOTH BALLS ON A
FELON, KNOWN LIAR THAT
OBSTRUCTED JUSTICE, JOHN DEAN SO
HE CAN COMPARE TRUMP TO RICHARD
NIXON JUST LIKE HE COMPARED
GEORGE W. BUSH TO NIXON ALSO.
AN EMBARRASSING STUNT IS JUST
ONE SMALL PART OF THE DEMOCRAT'S
PLAN TO SMEAR, SLANDER OR
BESMIRCH PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THIS IS ABOUT POLITICS, 2020
INSTEAD OF PASSING LAWS, SERVING
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, MAKING US
SAFE AND SECURE AND MORE
PROSPEROUS.
DEMOCRATS ARE NOW ATTEMPTING TO
INVESTIGATE THE RUSSIA FOLKS FOR
A FIFTH TIME.
TODAY THEY MOVED FORWARD WITH A
PLAN.
THEY WANT TO GO AFTER THE A.G.
AND FORMER WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL,
DON McGAHN IN CONTEMPT AND HOLD
THEM IN CONTEMPT FOR REFUSING TO
PARTICIPATE IN THEIR SHAM
HEARINGS.
CONGRESSMAN CUMMINGS IS PLANNING
TO HAVE MORE SHAM HEARINGS,
BARR, WILBUR ROSS IN CONTEMPT
FOR NOT TURNING OVER DOCUMENTS
RELATED TO THE U.S. CENSUS.
AS PER USUAL, DEMOCRATS ARE
ABUSING THEY POWER TO TURN THE
GOVERNMENT INTO A WEAPON AGAINST
POLITICAL OPPONENTS.
WE'LL HAVE MORE ON THAT IN JUST
A MOMENT.
FIRST, WE TURN TO THE 2020
CAMPAIGN TRAIL WATCH WHERE
SLEEPY UNCLE JOE BIDEN MADE
SEVERAL RARE APPEARANCES IN IOWA
AND THE SO-CALLED DEMOCRATIC'S
FRONTRUNNERS EVENT HAD A
WHOPPING 200 PEOPLE.
THAT'S ON THE HIGH SIDE.
200.
THAT'S IT.
THIS WAS A SPEECH HELY PROMOTED
BY HIS FRIENDS IN THE MEDIA MOB.
COMPARE THAT TO ANY TRUMP RALLY.
COMPARE THAT TO THE OUTSIDE OF
THE TRUMP RALLY.
A MASSIVE ENTHUSIASM GAP FOR
CRAZY UNCLE JOE.
NOT ONLY DOES BIDEN CARRY THE
WEIGHT OF THIS OBAMA-BIDEN TRACK
RECORD BUT THE FORMER VICE
PRESIDENT DOESN'T EXACTLY
INSPIRE ANY VOTERS.
TODAY ALL 85 AT ONE RALLY
ATTENDEES WERE TREATED TO A
MEANDERING RAMBLING 25-MINUTE
SPEECH WHERE SLEEPY CREEPY CRAZY
UNCLE JOE CALLED PRESIDENT TRUMP
A THREAT TO THE COUNTRY.
SUCH A POWERFUL STATEMENT BY
UNCLE JOE.
>> LOOK, I BELIEVE THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS LITERALLY AND
THREAT TO AMERICA.
HE'S A THREAT TO OUR CORE
VALUES.
AMERICA WAS BUILT IN A WAY --
BASIC CORE VALUES, DECENCY,
HONOR, LEAVE NOTHING ONE BEHIND,
REALIZING THERE'S THINGS BIGGER
THAN YOU IN AMERICA.
THAT WE HAVE TO GET TOGETHER,
COOPERATE.
THIS IS A GUY THAT DOES
EVERYTHING TO SEPARATE AND
FRIGHTEN PEOPLE.
IT'S ABOUT FEAR AND LOATHING.
>> Sean: SLEEPY CRAZY UNCLE JOE
IS NOT HAPPY THAT PRESIDENT
TRUMP CONTINUES TO QUESTION HIS
COMPETENCY FOR OFFICE.
ALL WE NEED TO DO IS LOOK BACK
AT THE EIGHT YEARS IN OFFICE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I'D RATHER RUN AGAINST BIDEN
THAN ANYBODY.
HE'S THE WEAKEST MENTALLY.
I LIKE RUNNING AGAINST PEOPLE
THAT ARE WEAK MENTALLY.
I THINK JOE IS THE WEAKEST UP
HERE.
THE OTHERS HAVE MORE ENERGY.
I DON'T AGREE WITH THEIR
POLICIES.
BUT I THINK JOE IS A MAN THAT
IS -- I CALLED HIM 1% JOE.
UNTIL OBAMA CAME ALONG, HE
DIDN'T DO WELL.
JOE BIDEN THOUGHT THAT CHINA WAS
NOT A COMPETITOR OF OURS.
JOE BIDEN IS A DUMMY.
JOE BIDEN THOUGHT CHINA WAS NOT
A COMPETITOR.
CHINA MADE $500 BILLION OVER A
SHORT PERIOD OF TIME AGAINST
OBAMA, BIDEN AND FOR MANY, MANY
YEARS.
>> Sean: AFTER DECADES IN THE
WASHINGTON SWAMP, CRAZY JOE
BIDEN HAS ACQUIRED A TON OF
BAGGAGE.
BILL MAHER SAID THAT HILLARY
OBSTRUCTED JUSTICE AND TAKING A
SHOT AT TRUMP.
SHE DID OBSTRUCT JUSTICE AND SHE
DID, WELL, COMMIT FELONIES.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THERE'S A LOT OF REASONS WHY
THE DEMOCRATS LOST AND MANY OF
THEM WERE HILLARY WAS A TERRIBLE
CANDIDATE.
THAT'S TRUE.
>> SHE DIDN'T HELP THE SITUATION
20 THE E-MAILS.
>> NO, SHE DIDN'T.
>> AND HER ACTIONS.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
RIGHT.
SHE COMMITTED OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE.
TRUMP DID I THINK IN MUCH WORSE
FASHION BUT YOU KNOW, SMASHING
UP YOUR PHONES AND HARD
DRIVES --
>> IT WAS BAD.
>> YEAH.
>> Sean: HAT TIP TO BILL MAHER.
HE TOLD THE TRUTH, A GUY ON THE
LEFT TOLD THE TRUTH.
GO AHEAD.